on Sunday night moonlight shocked
America by defeating heavily favored
Best Picture competitor voila Lin it one
for one simple reason those in Hollywood
decided that intersectionality should
defeat Hollywood self-aggrandizement
this year here's the thing about
moonlight not a very good movie it's
interesting in the way that all
character studies are kind of
interesting it's a look at a place and
at a time and at a person but it doesn't
truly uplift or sore or actually do much
of anything it won because the Academy
voters preferred not to hear another
year of griping about hashtag
oscarssowhite and because the same
voters could feel good about supposedly
slapping Donald Trump in the face with
diversity it's no coincidence that an
Oscar ceremony that open with Kimmel
tweeting president a tweaking president
Trump remember last year when it seemed
like the Oscars was racist ended with
the Academy giving the best picture
oscar to Brokeback inner-city Miami this
isn't to say there can't be a great
movie made about a black gay
coming-of-age story there can but this
wasn't it this isn't the first time the
Academy has vowed to political
correctness rather than quality of
course and this year's Oscar battle
featured two battling Hollywood
priorities honoring itself and honoring
the most politically correct picture of
the year in recent years this panel has
become pretty much the entirety of the
best picture race in 2014 Hollywood
rewarded its own importance with Birdman
instead of the far superior whiplash or
American sniper in 2013 Hollywood
rewarded the rather forgettable 12 years
of slave instead of gravity or Dallas
buyers club in 2012 Hollywood gave an
Oscar to Argo yay Hollywood does foreign
policy instead of zero dark thirty or
Lincoln in 2005 Hollywood had his
biggest pc off in the best picture fight
between Brokeback Mountain crash and
eunuch Capote was actually a better
picture than all of those three one of
the reasons Hollywood no longer rakes in
the big bucks other than on tentpole
features is that it sees only the
profound movies as those that center on
intersectional concerns upholding the
virtue of identity politics or the
importance of art itself rather than
movies to tell people stories that they
want to see lalaland is a far better
more watchable movie than moonlight but
there were at least three other movies
that were better than either this year
hell or highwater arrival and hacksaw
ridge and all three were nominated that
doesn't include what I felt was the most
entertaining flick of the year 10
Cloverfield Lane unfortunately for those
pictures they weren't concerned with
black gauge Hills render the wonders of
Hollywood if somebody ever makes a movie
about a half black half Native American
bisexual transgender trying to make his
or her way in Hollywood you can hand
them the Oscar right now and this is how
you know how it was
instead of telling particular stories
with general appeal how it would tell
stories that appeal only to themselves
they reassure themselves with their
importance every single year either by
making movies telling them how important
they are or by making movies trying to
show how important they are by taking on
the issue of the day in after-school
special fashion it doesn't make for good
entertainment which is why TV rat which
actually tell stories rather than
getting up hung up on the self-important
nonsense of the movie industry now
outranks the movie industry in terms of
quality I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
so we will talk everything Oscar's in
just a minute we will also be talking
about the Democrats cooking a new leader
and what you need to know about Tom
Perez that new leader but first we have
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
my patriots apply so if you're concerned
about the failure of local government to
help you in time of need if you're
concerned about economic downturn if
you're concerned about a natural
disaster you know the levees breaking
like it in Northern California or New
Orleans you're worried about just a
natural disaster of any sort of tornado
and you need to make sure that you are
safe and secure and that you have what
you need for your family you need to
talk to my friends and my patriots apply
they have a four-week emergency food
supply for only 99 bucks which is a
pretty solid price for four weeks of
emergency food supply is something you
buy once and then you never really have
to buy again these things last for 25
years you order now at 888 803 1413 88
88 0 3 14 13 or you can go online to
prepare with Ben com that's breakfast
lunch and dinner for 28 days so in case
the government can't help you or your
local community can't help you you're
prepared and for 99 bucks you never have
to worry about it again it stays fresh
again for 25 years it's only 99 bucks
plus free shipping limit two per caller
because you don't really have to worry
about it beyond that 888 803 1413 now
prepare with been calm again if you're
truly concerned you should be about
making sure your family has enough food
to eat if a crisis hits whether it's an
economic crisis or a natural disaster
you talk to my friends from my patriots
apply living in California this is one
of the companies that we turn to with
regard to to helping out friends and
family when given the fact that the
earthquakes are real possibility out
here and everywhere across the country
there is the possibility of natural
disaster you need to talk to my friends
over at my patriots apply 8888 03 14 13
8888 03 14 13 prepare with been calm is
the place to go online to get your my
patriots apply for weeks supply of
emergency food okay so we can jump right
into the oscar so the big winner at the
Oscars last night was not moonlight the
big winner at the Oscars last night was
Donald Trump that was the big winner at
the Oscars last night because Donald
Trump basically could sit there and
watch hollywood make a mockery of itself
sally kohn one of my favorite people on
the left of MSNBC and CNN pain you
remember her hands up don't shoot sally
kohn tweeted out right before the oscars
that she hoped every single speech was
political
switch I tweeted so do so does have a
Republican in the country we all want
every speech to be political because the
more political these speeches are the
better off Republicans are because
watching all of these all of these sort
of comforted rich limousine liberal
socialist ripping on America is really
something that off puts a lot of voters
and people react to that by voting for
people on the Republican side of the
aisle Hollywood has never driven people
into the arms of the Democrat acceptable
kind of their subtle cultural moment but
they don't drive people into the arms of
the Democrats by your shouting about how
terrible Republicans ours is something
that Hollywood gets wrong this stuff
that Hollywood is good at creating story
creating character that stuff can help
convince people that Democrats are right
but it doesn't convince people Democrats
are right when Marlon Brando sends up
Sheen little feather at the Oscars in
1973 Native American spokeswoman to pick
up his award and rant and rave about how
America's mean to the Native Americans
nobody voted Democrat because of that
and nobody voted Democrat in 2003
because Michael Moore got up at the
Oscars and talked about the fictional
president george w bush getting us into
a fictional war Hollywood people think
that we want to hear what they have to
say we don't we want to hear the stories
they have to tell but we don't actually
want to hear the things they have to say
because the things i have to say are
generally stupid they don't know
anything about politics so why in the
world would we listen to them when it
comes to politics but again Hollywood
doesn't know that so instead what
Hollywood does is they think that we're
watching because we want to hear their
opinions on politics so Jimmy Kimmel
just couldn't help himself he opened up
with a bunch of jokes about Trump here
were just a few of them it's so easy to
reach out in the heel we and I want to
say I maybe this is not
a popular thing to say but I want to say
thank you to president Trump I mean
remember last year when it seemed like
the Oscars were racist Braveheart in
this room and he's not going to unite us
either okay metal stand up if you would
everybody please join me in giving
marrow sleep a totally undeserved round
of applause really standing ovation
Camaro scream because he's married let's
be on hand Africa highly overrated no.37
artifical perfect it just hasn't been
good for 30 years and it was joke after
joke about Donald Trump and how terrible
Trump was and look how wonderful we are
we love Meryl Streep and Meryl Streep's
the best because she made fun of Donald
Trump that one time and some ceremony
and yeah we love her and sure she's in a
really crappy movie forrest foster
jenkins that nobody ever saw but it
doesn't matter because meryl streep guys
Meryl Streep so he does all of these
jokes in a row about Donald Trump and
we're all supposed to sit there and be
like yeah this is great yeah the real
reaction is can you guys get over
yourselves please really this is the
best that you can do these are your best
jokes about Donald Trump calling him
racist and calling presumably the people
who voted for him racist and it's a
great way to alienate an audience that's
already not watching any of your best
picture nominees nothing that was
nominated for best picture this year did
well at the box office I think the only
exception of as far as a movie that did
well at the box office was arrival I'm
not aware of any other movie that was
nominated for best picture this year
invented over 100 million in business
did arrival end up doing a hundred
million in business if it did it was
real close so it was it was it was not
it was not you know a blockbuster blow
out of the ballpark was a good movie i
enjoyed it but all of the movies that
were nominated this year again were seen
by pretty much the people in this
particular room and then it didn't stop
there the self aggrandizement of
hollywood is just unending viola davis
won best supporting actress for her role
in Suicide Squad no no no sorry was to
do no not for Suicide Squad it was dues
for her role in what was the name of
that moving fences fences sorry sorry I
got that wrong but Viola Davis who was I
thought she was fantastic in Suicide
Squad that's why I thought that she had
to win so was that guy who like shot
fired from his fingers never anyway
Viola Davis she gets up and she gives
this speech I became an artist and thank
God I did because we have the only
profession that celebrates what it means
to live a life we're the only profession
the only one that celebrates what it
means to live a life sounds complaining
before this before the show started
today that I'm kind of tired you know
the reason I'm kind of tired today
because my wife has woken up the last
several mornings at four o'clock in the
morning go into the hospital because she
is a she is a doctor and she's in her
residency which means she's getting up
at four o'clock in the morning to help
people who in some cases are terminally
ill clearly the only profession that
cares about living a life that honors
and celebrates living a life is
Hollywood and it's so just really when
viola davis says stuff like this the
fact is the vast majority of people in
the United States work jobs where
they're helping each other live better
lives but the artist has to pass
themselves on the back and is where I
was saying at the very beginning the
artisan Hollywood have to make
themselves feel important one of two
ways because otherwise they're just
reading lines for loving and wearing
funny costumes so they have to make
themselves feel important one of two
ways one is they make important stories
right we're gonna make a story about a
black gay ute living in Miami right
that's going to be the thing that makes
us important or alternatively we have to
talk about how important we are to
everybody else now I don't get on the
air every morning and talk about how
important my job is right I don't
because you see they're important to
yours is not important to you but I
don't have to preach how important what
I do is to you because you'll decide for
yourself and I think that's true for the
vast majority people when you call a
plumber he doesn't show up to your house
and go you know what it's really
important I fix your toilet today I'm
the guy who stands between you and crap
running over your floor and the deponent
doesn't do that just goes any fixes your
stuff but the artist community because
they understand that people sort of see
them as frivolous they feel the
necessity to go out and talk about how
special they are all the time and this
is not under estimating art I love art I
love the movies I love books I love
plays I drew I love the arts I grew up
in the arts my dad was somebody in the
arse my mom is somebody in the art my
sister is somebody in the two of my
sisters are people in the art I love the
arts they're fantastic and I write
novels I love the arts but you know art
is wonderful it's enriching it can
connect us to each other but the ever
arrogance the true arrogance is saying
the only profession that celebrate what
it means to live a life I mean that's
really astounding you know well
celebrates like literally everyone does
you know who L celebrates what it means
to live a life morticians right they
actually put together the funeral
arrangements where we remember people
there's also something that's really
it's real
high-handed about saying that only the
lives we choose to honor in Hollywood
are the important ones when she said in
this speech she said there's one place
all the people with the greatest
potential are gathered the graveyard
people ask me all the time what kind of
stories do you want to tell viola and I
say exhume those bodies exhume those
stories the stories of the people who
dream big I never saw those dreams to
fruition and this kind of stuff goes
over big in Hollywood mood rings ooh the
dreams oh yeah but the reality is the
vast majority of people in the graveyard
their stories will never be told but
they are still remembered by their
family their impact is still felt your
life doesn't end when your life ends
unless Viola Davis exhumes you and makes
a story about you you know with it
that's not even real right unless you
official story about a person who never
existed know what actually makes your
life important is the friends and family
around you in the way you impact the
world in a better way and the way that
you do honorable things for friends and
neighbors and make the world a better
place that's how you make the world a
better place there are a lot of people
who are remembered who are really evil
that doesn't make them more important it
doesn't make them more special you know
being remembered by people who actually
matter is I think more important than
Viola Davis remembering you and the idea
that Hollywood is what confers value on
people is really kind of growth and
another element of this and some people
like this some people hated it I didn't
like it was Jimmy Kimmel to this routine
where he ushered in a bunch of people
off the Hollywood tour bus directly into
the Oscars see the whole point of this
little stickier is to demonstrate just
how special Hollywood is it so special
you can bring people in off the street
and then you can show them to tell
magical Hollywood I mean look at all
these important people and look at all
these narrow do well rubes you know just
walking out what an honor for them what
an honor for them we brought in the
peasantry off the street and now the
peasants get to hobnob with a hoi polloi
die get to be among the stars see what
would have been great honestly and would
have been funnier is just Kimmel had
before that's taken a bunch of the stars
to visit people on their actual jobs all
right I've taken like me they make
movies about these actual jobs we've
been really funny to take chris pine for
example in hell or high water and take
him to an oil derrick and like show them
the people working in oil derrick right
or be really funny to take nicole kidman
and take her down to the local plumbers
Union and have her see what people are
actually doing over there because that
would have said okay look we're
Hollywood and we know what we do is kind
of frivolous and it brings meaning to
some people but we also understand that
what you do is really important instead
this whole event is all about how
Hollywood is super duper important all
lives in look it's fun I enjoy the
Oscars as much as the next guy although
I admit I did not watch a lot of it live
last night but at the same time this
sort of this sort of i'm going to look
down on you because we're from hollywood
more special it manifests itself not
just in terms of general attitude toward
the toward the people who live in the
middle of the country they're a bunch of
rednecks and rubes it also manifests
itself in terms of politics we're going
to talk more about that in just a second
but for that you have to go over to
daily wire calm right now and subscribe
you go for daily wire calm eight bucks a
month will make the subscriber today lee
weyer calm you can use the rest of the
show live and check it out over there
you can also get an annual subscription
right now at daily wire calm you get a
free copy of a piece of entertainment
that's actually conservative the arroyo
if you watched on friday we live stream
the film's you can actually see it the
Arroyo is a fictional film set on the
southern border about the crisis that's
taking place on our southern border 11
ranchers land is overrun by the drug
cartels and he has to figure out what to
do about it if you want to get a free
copy of that for you DVD that go today
lee weyer calm become an annual
subscriber otherwise eight dollars a
month makes you a subscriber and we are
late later you can listen to it on
itunes or soundcloud by the way if you
listen on itunes leave us a review we
really appreciate it we are the largest
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
you